welcome to this video playing casa pina
from from Brazil they've know that that
he or she whatever is some actually
playing on the server it's very frequent
chatter when there are top-level events
okay hmm very quickly played our 35
would be quite good my g4 okay okay yeah
I'm not sure should i do that or just
this come on let's just develop at the
end term this is six bond should should
irritate black maybe I should have
prevented that and now that I think of
it with the moves like em maybe even be
three or not immediately but somehow
prepare them prevent them
hmm
hmm cap difficult 92 maybe that I get to
see form but that some how do I make any
sense of these pawns they look
irritating can I may be prepared psac on
d6 Queen a six but between a six i might
play 9 p-5 asking him how do you develop
the bishop of the night hmm really I
take 9 p-5
92 with the alternative trying to get
the night to see form they are not clear
to me what's better but I guess this is
this is better in comparison to get the
night to see for should be should be
worth something
cannot play Knight a 6 i'm just taking
that mmm now taking is completely
completely useless right yes yeah okay
okay what about this position right here
i might play simply a 6 oh wait i can
actually go here and go to c6 if he
plays like a six and how does he ever
develop the night okay he allows that
probably because night c7 text my d5
pawn okay does this mean that yeah I
should probably go here Wow very
concrete all of the sudden rook b8 a4
and then knight c6
yeah okay but this is excellent now the
tonal knight on c6 should really
dominate the rooks at the right moment
I'm going to check the exchange only if
I'm only after thorough preparation but
I will play the King up to these three
and take on c3 and at the end try to
promote the big bottom it's not
necessary to rush with this he has no no
play whatsoever maybe even
no I can do it if I was okay
okay let's do that now
how to do that would be six right
no he cannot miss the rook yeah he met
him that I didn't ever had a check also
but it's like it's not it does not
matter I can just play night before
completely just doing it positionally
without any tactics
yeah just just prepare this a little bit
more time warning
check check check check check check
check mate this would have been really
really disappointing all right but ugh
be one simply because of this this
complete domination but this is really
cute i cannot he cannot move anything
okay I should have should have used this
tactic here when it here I think there
was some point where I could could
actually play a night if I I couldn't
jump yeah okay well this this is what's
this was okay in it it is winning but
yeah here I was a bit fiat fiat here
this one but i have Roxy 70 yeah this is
so this is very clear okay yeah I was I
wasn't sure and at the end I decided to
go for that it was always winning but
yeah it looks wrong here he needs to
give up e 7 or h4 who allowed the beep
on to promote and he never he never can
allow this knight on c6 this eternal
night some here 97's not to play we move
he needs to do something else I mean
I know I know but you cannot allow that
what happened and I think here I was
really surprised that he didn't play
rugby aid he must play with beard and
then I must play a form this is entirely
different animal with before a weekend
it's still interesting this position
with 96 but it's it's far far superior
to the game from black point of view
this is just an unplayable unplayable I
think it's its base it's not possible to
prevent what happened here this kind of
domination okay thanks for watching